monsieur le premier ministre comme
chaque mois de janvier le président
chaque mois de janvier le président de
la république ouvre les yeux sur la
situation critique de la france après
avoir saboté méthodiquement l'économie
française pendant trois ans il est
aujourd'hui au pied du mur il a donc
formulé hier des propositions dans la
panique et l'urgence le président
voulait une union nationale contre le
chômage
mais comment voulez-vous réaliser une
union basé sur le mensonge la création
de 500 milles formation pour les
demandeurs d'emploi est inatteignable ce
dispositif qui double le nombre de
formations est irréalisable et vous le
savez il viendra accroître les
désespoirs des français faute d'emplois
à la clé ces demandeurs reviendront
malheureusement à pôle emploi aussi vite
qu'ils en sont partis après trois ans
trois plans dédié à l'apprentissage
depuis 2014
les dégâts sont là une chute
spectaculaire de 32000 apprentis vous
avez tout fait pour que l'apprentissage
échoue en réduisant les crédits dédiés
vous avez choisi sciemment de
privilégier les contrats aidés au
détriment de l'apprentissage et que de
temps perdu concernant les baisses de
charges pour les entreprises
pourquoi avoir créé le cic est il pas
avoir immédiatement baisser les charges
les primes à l'emploi que vous avez
annoncé n'intéresse pas les entreprises
les entreprises ne demande pas l'aumône
elles attendent de vraies réformes et
vous proposer de coups de feu de paille
ce plan d'urgence ou plutôt fait dans
l'urgence coûtera 2 milliards d'euros
alors que les comptes publics se porte
toujours aussi mal vous avez abandonné
vos objectifs de finances publiques pour
de pures raisons électoralistes avec 5.5
millions de chômeurs la france décroche
un peu plus chaque jour
nous créons neuf fois moins d'emplois
marchands que l'allemagne - clis pas
aide - kigali
dans le même temps le gouvernement a
créé 2 133 1000 emplois dans le secteur
public
cherchez l'erreur alors malgré le défilé
des plans et des pactes en tout genre
les entreprises sont encore sous le choc
fiscal à caen caen reviendrez-vous sur
de véritables réformes ambitieuses
notamment sur le code du travail ce plan
est une nouvelle occasion ratée pour la
france dans un accès de lucidité votre
ministre de l'économie déclaré on n'a
pas tout fait pour l'emploi les temps
monsieur emmanuel macron
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le
ministre je pense qu'on pourrait revenir
sur toutes les batailles passées ou
perdu si collectivement nous avions su
traiter le problème du chômage dans
notre pays nous n'en serions
collectivement pas là et donc il est
évident que ce n'est pas un plan en lui
seul qui va régler le problème du
chômage mais il faut le réinscrire dans
une dynamique essayer de voir où on va à
quoi répond à quoi répondent les
annonces qui ont été hier faite par le
président de la république
d'abord à la volonté d'aller vers plus
de visibilité donnée aux entreprises
lorsqu'elles embauches et donc le
président réaffirmé la volonté sa
volonté de voir inscrire dans la loi le
plafonnement des dommages et intérêts
aux prud'hommes c'est une mesure
importante vous le savez bien
elle est attendue par les entrepreneurs
par celles et ceux qui embauchent elles
donnent de la sécurité c'est une réalité
mais vous pouvez protester c'est une
réalité elle vient compléter une réforme
qui a d'ores et déjà été conduites
car à proposer le président de la
république hier qu at il annoncé sa
volonté de précisément transformer le
séisme en allègements de charges
c'est-à-dire cette volonté dans le temps
de graver cet allègement fiscal en
allègements de charges c'est-à-dire de
donner de la visibilité aux
entrepreneurs c'est ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ce qu'ils veulent
vous pouvez protesté sur l'abandon de du
sérieux budgétaire c'est faux c'est faux
les chiffres qui ont été rappelés la
semaine dernière par michel sapin et
christian eckert l'ont encore montré
il n'y a pas à cet égard de
laisser-aller et au delà de ce talent le
président de la république a campé une
série de principes sur la base
desquelles nous allons travailler dans
les prochaines semaines myriam el khomri
sur la loi qu'elle aura à proposer en
matière de réforme du droit du travail
qui donnera plus de souplesse d'une part
au niveau justement de l'entreprise et
de la branche et d'autre part en ouvrant
une voie complémentaire la création
d'emplois par l'entrepreneuriat et le
parcours de croissance on ne répond pas
à tous on ne répondra pas à tous dans
les trois mois mais il faut aussi de
bonne foi que de manière réciproque nous
ayons la lucidité de voir les bilans et
elle nous inventions mises en abyme
drôle et à monsieur françois l'ongle